[Musique]
et
là je te pas nouveau on a souvent
tendance à opposer la radio à la
télévision et même à considérer la radio
souvent comme un vieux machin qui date
d'avant guerre bon évidemment je suis
d'accord lorsqu'il y a de bons
programmes à la télévision la plus
grande partie de l'audience est
hypnotisé par le petit écran mais je
vous rappelle que france inter et mes 24
heures sur 24 et que la télévision
française est encore loin du compte pour
l'instant donc il y à des heures
privilégié pour lundi les 1 où il n'y a
pas de programme télévision et ce sont
ces heures dans lesquels nous essayons
de mettre des programmes spécialement
attractifs et que nous soignons
particulièrement c'est le cas notamment
à 9 heures du matin avec pierre
bouteiller et vous connaissez presque
tous cet indicatif
[Musique]
et
bonjour quand on écoute régulièrement
votre mission on a quelquefois
l'impression d'un immense bric à brac on
parle un peu de tout c'est exact je
crois qu'il ya pas de limite à cette
émission dont la formule est de ne pas
en avoir
évidemment elle est axé plus
particulièrement sur les loisirs le
spectacle de théâtre la musique et
disques la danse la mode mais tout ce
qui fait la culture au sens chinois je
veux dire la qualité de la vie un
certain mode de vie ce qui fait je crois
qu'on peut parler de tout ça dépend de
la manière dont madame je vois avec
plaisir une boîte géante de super
lessive à tous pourquoi avez vous choisi
du ch pourquoi s'il s'il décide ça lave
ne pas se la faire cette émission
magazine non à une mini-équipe que le
film s'attribuer généreusement
c'est-à-dire avec richard hulot qui
s'occupe de la partie technique bernard
2 et philippe aubert pour les reportages
et ses équipes ont essayé de couvrir le
plus de choses possible dans la vie
passée le mans parisienne des voix les
téléspectateurs vous connaissent parce
qu'on commence à vous voir un petit peu
la télévision pas trop où enfin j'espère
la personnalité oui même quand on ne
vous voit pas et qu'on se contente de
les écouter à la radio on a toujours
l'impression que un petit sourire
ironique du sourire cynique un peu
d'humour
on dit même quelques fois que vous êtes
méchant fille d'accord pour les trois
premières propositions pas pour la
dernière je ne crois pas être méchant
mais j'ai un refus devant laisser conter
je cours je suis comme vous je ne veux
pas être dupe de toutes les entreprises
de matraquage de manipulation et sur
toutes les choses dont je suis amené à
parler dans l'émission je porte un
regard disons critique un peu distanciée
mais ce n'est jamais méchant mais en
1947 fille de parents pauvres mais
honnête meriem mature représente
laventure la plus typique est la plus
réussie système à l'intérieur duquel
fonctionne le show business français
piquemal ionisé par une sorte de génie
du marketing
johnny stark plus connu dans les
chaumières sous le nom de pépé joue
mireille mathieu et la vedette française
par excellence à ce rang depuis 1965 la
relève d'edith piaf dont on a su
intelligemment lui faire abandonner la
simulation plus ou moins consciente
9h10 du matin calais quel est votre
client
l'heure du petit déjeuner déjà terminée
trois cas de sorte de clientèle d'une
part les femmes qui sont chez elle une
fois que leur mari alors sans fin son
parti dans une clientèle féminine et
d'autre part les gens les hommes qui ont
la chance de pouvoir écouter la radio du
béret chance à cette heure là c'est à
dire en grande partie une grosse
clientèle automobilistes et peut-être
une sorte de quarantaine de cadres qui
sont encore chez ea store mal y en a
dans votre émission vous parlez de
médecine ne vous parler d'art culinaire
parler de tes ratures cinéma de disques
enfin un peu de tout mais on vous
reproche souvent d'être un peu parisien
et oui je crois pas que leurs proches
soient justifiées d'abord les studios
sont à paris il pas et d'autres enfin
vous savez très bien que dans un pays
aussi centralisé comme il l'est depuis
napoléon tout passe par paris mais je
crois que les auditeurs de province ont
ravi d'une part de savoir ce qu'il passe
pas ce qui se passe à paris à la
condition qu'on ne les oublie pas
complète mais on les oublie facilement
et j'avais envie à mon second point
c'est que très souvent les missions
comme les autres de la chaîne à
l'occasion d'aller en province et dire
ou pas rien ce qui se passe en province
alors je ne crois pas a mérité ce
reproche de parisianisme vous voyez à
l'échelle nationale donc tous les matins
sur france inter à 9 heures
écoutez le magazine de pierre bouteiller
vous serez au courant de toute
l'actualité dans tous les domaines et
vous en parlera toujours avec beaucoup
de gentillesse pas trop de méchanceté et
toujours avec vous
[Musique]